before he leaves England the president
and the first lady will sit down with
Queen Elizabeth she has met nearly every
one of the last 12 presidents Wow
talk about living through history
president Trump has said he is looking
forward to the meeting describing the
Queen as an incredible woman Charlie
d'Agata is at Windsor Castle just west
of London with more on the long
tradition that American leaders share
with British royalty
Charlie good morning good morning to you
and what has become a bumpy ride this
visit may become a welcome relief as you
said the president is already discussed
how much they're looking forward to it
he says the first lady is a tremendous
fan in sixty-six years on the throne the
Queen has seen nearly a dozen US
presidents come and go we know what is
right
freedom is right she's met them all with
the exception of Lyndon Johnson and
while she and the current President may
have different personalities royal
biographer Robert Hardman doesn't see a
problem they actually have quite a lot
in common they both got Scottish mothers
they both own fairly large parts of
Scotland in her case Balmoral in his
case two golf courses and she's used to
dealing with the most appalling despots
monsters crooks dictators sending up
Donald Trump coming for tea I think
you're gonna get on great one of the
more memorable visits was that of John
and Jacqueline Kennedy just months after
his inauguration in 1961 some
relationships have been warmer than
others Ronald Reagan became the first
u.s. president to overnight at Windsor
Castle even horse-riding with the Queen
the Reagan's it was a really really warm
friendship I mean once when the Queen
was in California with the royal yacht
it was the Reagan's wedding anniversary
and she invited them around for a for a
special wedding anniversary dinner and
they all ended up around the piano
singing
sing-alongs aside President Trump and
First Lady Melania might be expected to
follow protocol as they're not British
subjects of bow and curtsey isn't
technically required but appreciated
it's also polite not to turn your back
on the Queen and even touching can get a
bit touchy people would say you
shouldn't touch the Queen and you
shouldn't really get around touching the
Queen but there's that famous story of
Michelle Obama allegedly putting a hand
around the Queen what people forget is
the Queen actually put her hand round
Michelle Obama now in terms of protocol
it is possible maybe even likely that
the Queen will discuss world affairs she
is the head of state after all but
traditionally her views do not extend
beyond those castle walls
John Charlie d'Agata in Windsor thanks I
think that's means it's all going to be
a secret to be a fly on the wall